PROFESSOR: Since z, that's
straight up.
And that is going to provide
for you a cell that has the
shape of a square prism.
This would be a1.
This would be a2.
And this would be a3--
I'm sorry, this would be c.
And if you took the choice for
the third translation as 1/2
half of a1 plus 1/2 of a2 plus
some amount z up above the
base of the cell, and then
redefined a T3 prime that
would be equal to--
sorry.
What am I doing here?
Yeah.
This is right.
1/2 of a1 1/2 of a2,
and z straight up.
Define a T3 prime as 2T3
minus a1 minus a2.
And that will define for you,
again, a cell in the shape of
a square prism with a1 and a2.
And now the translation that
went up directly over the
center of the base
of the net below.
Twice that minus a2 minus a1
brings you back to a third
translation T3 prime that's
normal to the base.
So both cells have
the same shape.
This is a primitive.
This is a body-centered
tetragonal lattice.
And the symbol that's used to
represent the body-centered
lattice is I. One of the few
cases, again, where one has to
be bilingual.
The German word for
body-centered is
innenzentriert.
So there's Schoenflies
at work again.
So primitive body-centered
represented by I.
And that brings us to one final
case, and that is the
plane groups that have
a hexagonal shape.
And here we have a funny
situation in that the same
choices of the third translation
do not work for
all of the plane groups.
If you have a base
to the cell--
and again, the two edges
of that net are
identical by symmetry--
if it has a three-fold axis in
it and nothing else, than
there are two choices.
You can either have T3 be equal
to 0a1 plus 0a2 and an
amount z straight up.
And that will give you a cell
that is a primitive cell.
This would be a1.
This would be a2.
And just as we did for
tetragonal, we'd call the
third axis c, This will work
for a three-fold axis.
So there is a space group P3.
This will also work for all
of the other groups.
So there's P3M1 and a P31M.
And a P6 will work.
And a P6mm will work.
So look it here.
We've got five additional space
groups in addition to
the lattice type.
This is the primitive
hexagonal lattice.
For a three-fold axis, we
have another choice.
We could pick T3 so that it
took the origin three-fold
axis and put it directly
over this one.
Looks as though you could have
a different distinct lattice
if you move the origin lattice
point over the three-fold axis
that sits at a location
1/3, 2/3.
This one is at 2/3, 1/3.
Let me demonstrate, I think
convincingly and clearly, that
those two choices are exactly
the same thing.
And the way that I can show that
is, once again, to draw
this net a1, a2.
And suppose I pick the part of
the offset of T3 that is
within the plane of the net as
going from this lattice point
to this one here.
Then if I go twice that
translation T3, that's gonna
put me directly over this
three-fold axis.
And if I go three translations
T3, I'll be directly over the
lattice point on the
ground floor.
So putting the original lattice
point over this
three-fold axis or this
three-fold axis is exactly the
same thing.
And I can change one into the
other just by flipping this
thing 180 degrees.
So it's obviously
the same choice.
This description of T3, if I
define the direction of c now
as 3T3 defined in this fashion,
minus a1 minus a2, is
gonna be a funny situation.
It's gonna be a peculiar sort of
double body-centered cell.
Of course, along the long
diagonal of the hexagonal
cell, I'll have one lattice
point that's 1/3 of the way
along that long diagonal, and
another interior lattice point
that's 2/3 of the way along
that long diagonal.
OK.
This double body-centered cell,
so to speak, actually
can be redefined in terms of
a primitive cell, not a
primitive cell that is this
particular description of a
primitive hexagonal lattice.
This is not a primitive
hexagonal lattice.
But suppose I go from this
interior lattice point along
the long diagonal of the
cell to this location
and call that a1.
Remember that there is a
three-fold axis sneaking down
through the center of this
triangle, goes through the
lattice point, and comes
out the center of
the triangle below.
If I go up to this lattice point
and up to this lattice
point, I have three translations
that are
straddling the three-fold
axis.
And that three-fold axis rotates
one into the other.
So this new definition of
a cell that is in fact
primitive a1, a2--
and they're all equivalent
by symmetry.
I always get in trouble when
I try to draw it, but that
actually defines a cell
with a shape that
we've not seen before.
That is a cell that has the
shape of a rhombohedron.
And as I say, I always get in
trouble when I try to draw it.
It's got three translations
like this and three
translations skewed by 60
degree sitting on top.
Everybody can see that's a
rhombohedron, can't you?
Say yes.
Be nice.
So this is another primitive
cell that's a choice for this
triple cell.
And this consequently gives
its name to this lattice.
This is called a rhombohedral
lattice, regardless of whether
you pick the primitive cell in
the shape of the rhombohedron
or this peculiar double
body-centered cell.
So this is a rhombohedral
lattice.
And this is represented in a
space group symbol by the
letter R, standing
for rhombohedral.
So just the three-fold axis
with this choice of
translations, that would
be space group R3.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
a1 like this. a2 like this. a3,
I'm taking a right-handed
system, comes from the centered
lattice point.
So let me draw it
in projection.
It's easier to see.
Here's the outline of
the hexagonal net.
Here's the three-fold axis.
And I've taken a1 coming
up like this.
I've taken a2 coming up out
of the board like this.
And I've taken a3 coming
out like this.
OK.
So these are the three edges
of the rhombohedron.
Notice that I cannot have that
lattice with a lot of the
hexagonal plane groups.
I cannot do it for
six-fold axis.
Because a six-fold axis--
P6 and P6MM have a six-fold axis
here and three-fold axes
in the middle of the cell.
So I cannot have a rhombohedral
lattice for P6 or
P6<M. The primitive hexagonal
lattice is the
only thing that works.
And then we have this curious
situation with the two
alternative settings of point
group 3M in a hexagonal net,
P3M1 and P31M.
For P3M1, I have symmetry 3M
at both the origin lattice
point and in the center of
these two triangles.
So for P3M1, in addition to a
three-fold axis, I could put
in 3M1, stack up plane
group P3M1.
But I cannot do this for 31M.
That's impossible.
Because if you look at P31M,
there is symmetry 3M at the
origin and only symmetry 3 in
the center of the triangles.
So if I try to pick this as a
third translation for plane
group P31M, I'm taking symmetry
3M and plopping it
down on top of symmetry 3, and
that wrecks the plane group.
So for the rhombohedral
lattice, I can
only have 3M1 or P3.
P6 has a six-fold axis at the
origin lattice point.
The two centers of the triangles
are three-fold axes.
So primitive for the six-fold
axis, either P6 or P6MM, is
the only choice.
So if anybody's counting--
and I wasn't--
we've got 11 lattices so far.
And the only ones that we
haven't been able to get by
simple stacking of the plane
groups are the systems that
you all know as your
favorites.
The cubic or isometric stems
for the fact that the
translations are identical
in all three directions.
Let me quickly dispose of
those by starting with a
four-fold axis coming out of one
face of a tetragonal cell
and saying now if this is a
cubic symmetry, I have a
three-fold access that comes
out, sort of, in the direction
of a body diagonal.
But this three-fold axis is
gonna rotate that four-fold
access to this direction
and to this direction.
We've seen that if I look down
along the diagonal of a
equally axed tetragonal prism,
the three-fold axis takes this
face, rotates it into this
face, and rotates
it into this face.
So I have to have a four-fold
axis coming out of every one
of the faces.
And having that arrangement of
four-fold axes means that not
only will the two translations
be identical in the base of
the cell, as is the case for
tetragonal, but if I put in
that three-fold axis as an
extender, all three edges of
the cell have to be identical
by symmetry.
So I can do this for a primitive
tetragonal lattice.
And that's gonna give me a
primitive isometric lattice.
I can do this for a
body-centered tetragonal lattice.
So that would be indicated by
the symbol I. So it's a
body-centered cubic lattice.
And if you add up everything
we've done to this point,
there are 13 space lattices,
a very unlucky number.
And as you all know,
there are 14.
We've missed one.
So what have we not done?
We stacked up all the plane
groups in all possible ways.
We've taken the four-fold axes
out of the face normals, all
three face normals of
a tetragonal cell.
And that forced it to become
a cubic lattice.
What have we done wrong?
Actually, we can get the
fourteenth space lattice by a
little bit of sleight of hand
that is not obvious.
Let's say that this is the base
of a tetragonal lattice
that we used as the parent
for our cubic lattice.
Let me change that primitive
square in the base of the
tetragonal cell and change it
into a centered square.
There'd be no reason for doing
that for a plane group.
But let me notice now that if
this is the direction of a
four-fold axis, rather than
having the three-fold axis
come out of this direction
relative to this super double
square, I can make the
three-fold axis come out in
this direction.
Ah-ha.
So what I have now is a cell
that is centered, has a center
in the base and has translations
that are
perpendicular to the
base like this.
And if this is the direction of
the four-fold axis and this
is the direction of the
three-fold axis, that
three-fold axis is going to put
a centered lattice point
on the remaining faces
of the cube.
So it's only if I notice I can
make a double square base to
the cell again, put the
three-fold axis of a cubic
symmetry along the direction
of the body diagonal, I
generate lattice points in the
middle of the other faces as
well, and this gives me the
lattice known as F, the
face-centered cubic lattice.
And the edges of the cell here
are all identical, equivalent
by symmetry.
So they're labeled a1, a2, a3.
Have you ever seen a lattice
constant for a
cubic crystal a0?
Has anybody ever seen that?
A lot of people do it.
And if you see that notation in
a publication, you will be
entitled to sneer
at it knowingly.
It's logical, three,
two, one, zero.
By extrapolation, if you've
got an a3, an a2, a1, you
gotta have an a0, right?
Well, not necessarily.
That sort of algebra
doesn't apply to
labeling of cell edges.
It comes from a curious
historic precedent.
Come back, again, to the fact
that for literally more than
100 years, people developed
symmetry theory and had a
pretty good idea that crystals
were based on packing of
units, molecules, whatever they
were, that were on the
nodes of a lattice.
But they couldn't measure the
size and shape of the lattice.
And that was the brilliance of
the famous experiment by Max
von Laue because that, in one
fell swoop, show that the
mysterious radiation x-rays
were just electromagnetic
radiation of a very
short wavelength.
And that's what he really
gained notoriety for.
But at the same time, he proved
for the first time,
unequivocally, that crystals
were based on a lattice.
And that was the other side
of his double-edged
accomplishment.
Up until that time, people
learned about crystals by
studying the morphology and
measuring the angles between
crystal faces and recording
different faces on a crystal.
I mean, I can just see one of
these old guys working a
little bit before his wife made
him come down and sit for
supper because it was
getting cold.
And he'd let out
a, whoop, huh?
A 13 27 face.
What the hey.
It's a new face on potassium
tartrate, something like that.
This was the way these guys
got their jollies.
And on the basis of the angles
between faces, as I said on
several occasions, they could
determine a ratio of axes, a
ratio of a to b to c, if their
assignment of indices to faces
were correct.
And how did you know?
Well, along came x-rays, a and
you could measure for sure.
So what people started doing
to distinguish a to b to c
ratios determined from crystal
morphology, they put the zeros
on it to indicate real values
from diffraction.
And when little people came
afterwards and they didn't
realize the reason for doing
that-- nobody's done this for
over 100 years because everybody
determines lattice
constants using diffraction--
but some people have
seen these zeros.
So they say, I'm not doing
proper notation.
And you know how furious
crystallographers get if you
don't use proper notation.
So let me write a0
as the lattice
constant of my cubic crystal.
You see this commonly.
And there's been no need
for it for 100 years.
So anyway, that's the origin
of the subscript zero.
There are a lot of dumb things
that take place among normally
rational people.
I said a moment ago--
and I crossed my
fingers when I said it--
that c is the label that is
assigned to the unique axis,
the axis that is unique
because of symmetry.
Sometimes you see monoclinic
crystals, which have a
two-fold axis and/or a mirror
plane perpendicular to the
two-fold axis, labelled with
this as b, this is a, and this
as c, and the angle between
them-- that's the general
obtuse angle--
as beta.
There is a story behind
this lapse of
standardness in notation.
How do people decide on what
proper notation is?
Well, there is an organization
called the International Union
of Crystallography, which
is the equivalent of the
International Union of Pure and
Applied Physics and the
International Union of Pure
and Applied Chemistry.
And they meet every
three years.
And there are special
commissions for people who
like to fight and argue out
conventions and nomenclature.
And this is such a silly
abomination that there was a
move made when they came out
with their new edition of
international tables to change
this and do it the way you do
for all of the other crystal
systems, namely a, b with
gamma between them, and c coming
out this way as the
direction of the
two-fold axis.
And this would be the
mirror plane.
And that would put this in
accord with tetragonal and
hexagonal and everything else.
And it was logical and seemed
the right thing to do.
So how do people decide
on nomenclature?
This is something that people
fight with with more passion
than anything else in science.
So you make a proposal.
The proposal goes to the
national committees of
crystallography in countries
over the world.
They discuss it.
They fight about it.
They vote on it.
Then it comes back to the
International Union.
And finally, if everybody seems
agreed, they present it
at the next meeting of the
International Union Of
crystallography for a vote.
And that's exactly what happened
with the proposal to
standardized notation.
This took place maybe, I don't
know, in the 1950s.
Everybody was in favor.
The discussion proceeded
rationally.
Then this little guy jumps up
in the front row, short of
stature, balding of head, with
a very piercing nasal voice.
And he gets up and he enters
into this diatribe.
b-axis unique was good
enough for Curie.
enough for Mauguin.
B-axis unique was-- and all
the names were French.
Actually, he wasn't French.
He was Belgian.
So he went on and on and on.
And he so cowed this group of
300 rational delegates, that
they didn't cave in entirely.
What they did was they entered
every entry for monoclinic
crystals in the international
tables twice, once with this
set of labels, once with
this set of labels.
And to indicate that this was
the preferred notation, this
is labeled the first setting.
And to indicate second-class
citizenship no matter what
Curie, Mauguin, Bravais, and all
of these other guys felt,
this was called the
second setting.
And I'm not kidding.
I'll bring in a copy of the
international tables for x-ray
crystallography.
Every entry for a monoclinic
crystals is in there twice.
AUDIENCE: And no one in the past
50 years has tried to get
rid of the second set?
PROFESSOR: No.
Actually, the reason is
it is expensive to
revise these tables.
And I brought in on the first
day, you don't remember, my
copy of international tables
for x-ray crystallography,
which is about this
big and cost $100.
And then the new version
which is twice as large
dimensionally, four times as
heavy in terms of weight, and
I think about eight times
as expensive in
terms of actual cost.
So you don't do this casually.
If there's something actually
new comes out, you make a
little supplement that
people can stick
in the pages somewhere.
AUDIENCE: Don't they still have
PDFs nowadays or something?
PROFESSOR: The last volume came
out before PDF, before
very intensive use of computers
for such data.
The journals now are
all done online.
You submit papers online and
they're archived online as
well in addition to hard copy.
But that's something that was
before the time of the
publication of the last
set of volumes.
Well, I am almost done with
talking about lattices.
But I have a thought question.
You've all heard of this castle
in Ireland that has
this famous rock in the side
of the castle called the
blarney stone?
And you, to get the gift of gab,
have to lean over this
rather dangerous wall and
somebody holds your ankles and
you go down and you kiss
the blarney stone.
And that gives you supposedly
the gift of gab.
But kissing is a dangerous
occupation.
You've all heard about kissing
disease mononucleosis?
And with all those people
smooching the blarney stone,
I've always been afraid the
blarney stone might
come down with mono.
And if the blarney stone became
ill in this session,
would it have to be
transferred to the Mono Clinic?
I don't know.
All right.
Here in all their glory are
the 14 space lattices, or
Bravais lattices as they're
finally called.
The labels a, b, c, et cetera,
are not on them, but the c
axis is vertical.
You'll see that the hexagonal
rhombohedral lattice is shown
referred to hexagonal axes.
In the international tables,
you will find all the
information both referred to
rhombohedral lattices and to
the triple hexagonal
cell as well.
Now, into these lattices one
should drop those of the 32
point groups that the lattices
can accommodate.
That's gonna be a lot
of additions.
Besides that, there is the
option of having the symmetry
elements of the point group
not intersect at a common
point, but interleave them as we
did, for example, with the
glide planes in P2GG, and
in some of the other
two-dimensional plane
groups as well.
Then we would do what we also
did in two dimensions, take
the mirror planes and replace
them by glide
planes, one or the both.
And you might think that we
really have an enormous amount
of work to do.
We haven't considered any
symmetry combinations that
involve a horizontal
mirror plane.
For example, we look at what
symmetry 2 requires and we
found the primitive monoclinic
lattice, and the side-centered
monoclinic lattice, and the
body-centered monoclinic lattice.
So there's more than one lattice
type into which we can
drop a given point group.
But what would you have if
you had a mirror plane
perpendicular to the
two-fold axis?
What kind of lattice
will that require?
OK.
Let me, in one masterful swoop,
convince you that we
have done almost the better
part of the work.
Let us ask what does inversion
require of a lattice?
What does the symmetry of
inversion, which didn't appear
in any of the plane groups at
all because that's inherently
a three-dimensional point
group operation?
Well, think about it.
All inversion says is that, if,
hey, there's a translation
that goes up this way, there
should be another translation
minus T in the opposite
direction.
And any lattice whatsoever can
make that claim and satisfy
that requirement.
So let me now just quickly say
that if we have derived the
lattice types, and by
implication the space groups
as well, for a two-fold axis,
for a four-fold axis, for a
six-fold axis, and so on, we
have automatically satisfied
the requirements for any point
group that results when you
add inversion to a two-fold
axis, when you add inversion
to a four-fold axis, or add
inversion to a six-fold axis.
So it turns out that the
requirements of a six-fold
axis, which gave us the
primitive hexagonal lattice,
are also met by 6 over M. The
requirements of a four-fold
axis, which gave us the lattices
primitive tetragonal
and body-centered tetragonal,
are also satisfied for 4 over
M.
So, any one of the
point groups that
differs from the 11--
from the 10 two-dimensional
symmetries--
namely 1, 2, 3, 4, 6, M,
2MM, 3M, 4MM, and 6MM--
any symmetry that you get by
adding inversion to those
two-dimensional point groups is
automatically going to be
happy in the space lattices
that we've
derived to this point.
So we have done an enormous
fraction of the work that's
required to derive space
lattices, and the
space groups as well.
So there is not too much
more to be done.
And what I will do for probably
the next meeting is
to derive a few of the space
groups for the lower
symmetries which are not too
complicated, just to show you
how the game plays out.
And then I will mention a little
bit about the special
idiosyncrasies of the
orthorhombic brick-shaped
cells where there is nothing
more distinct about one
direction and the other.
All the inter-axial angles
are 90 degrees.
The translations are general.
So there are peculiarities in
notation there that are unique
to the orthorhombic system.
And then I want to spend,
perhaps, one class talking a
little bit about crystal
chemistry.
Have any of you had a class in
solid state chemistry or
crystal chemistry?
OK.
One.
One of the main uses of space
group theory is the
description of crystal
structures.
So I think I might, as a minor
digression, take an hour to
talk about packing and some of
the concepts used to describe
the close-packed structures and
ionic structures and give
you a problem that ask you, as
I already did, to generate a
structure, simple-minded
two-dimensional structure, and
do some interpretation of it.
So, I think this will be worth
saying a little bit about just
so that one of the main
applications of symmetry
theory does not escape without
any discussion at all.
We will, after about two more
lectures, have a complete
change of direction and start
talking about properties of
crystals and how these
properties are impacted by the
fact that crystals
have symmetry.
So we're gonna use some of our
results in symmetry, but not
all that much, but develop
remarkable mileage in
predicting anisotropy in
crystals just on the basis of
the symmetry which that crystal
possesses, that
certain physical properties as
a function of direction are
weird surfaces that have lumps
and noses and bulges in them.
And certain properties have this
anisotropy universally,
regardless of the chemistry or
composition of the crystal.
Given the symmetry of the
crystal, the anisotropy has to
be in this fashion.
We'll be able to show that some
properties simply cannot
exist, period, regardless of
composition and structure in
materials that have certain
symmetries.
So that'll be the direction
we take off in.
I mentioned at the beginning of
the term-- you've probably
forgotten--
there is a lovely book on
tensors and physical
properties by a gentleman named
J. F. Nye, N-Y-E. And
the title of the book
is Physical
Properties of Crystals.
This is a nice place to go
for further reading.
We will go through roughly
half of Nye's book with a
little more emphasis on the
consequences of symmetry than
what he does.
But if you want to do some extra
reading, I asked the
Coop to stock this book.
But I suggest that you not
rush out and buy it.
It's available in paperback,
which means it's cheap, but
only relatively so.
There's no such thing as
a cheap technical book,
paperbacked or not,
these days.
It's also on reserve
in the library.
So, see if you need
the extra help.
See if you would like to
do some reading in Nye.
And make sure you want to before
you go out and put your
money down at the Coop.
The last part of Nye
is an elegant,
beautiful part of the book.
It deals with the thermodynamic
relations
between different properties.
And it's a unique treatment
that is developed by Nye.
We won't do any of that, but
it's a nice thing to have.
So don't rush out and
spend your money.
But if you want additional
reading and just going to the
reserved book collection is not
enough, then Nye is not at
all a bad copy of
a book to have.
I think most of you have
probably seen Nye, not the
book but the man.
How many of you have seen the
famous Bragg bubble raft movie
on disk locations, where he
floats sheets of bundles and
sheers them and you see his
dislocation go zipping across?
At one stage in that movie,
there's an assistant who
tiptoes, trying to be
unobtrusive, across the
background.
But the camera catches him
scurrying behind Bragg.
That's Nye.
So if you've seen the
movie, you've seen
what Nye looks like.
OK.
I'll call it quits
there for today.
And we'll see you next
week on Tuesday.